die würde des menschen ist unantastbar
so lautet der erste satz des
grundgesetzes der bundesrepublik
deutschland von 1948
der satz ist eine reaktion auf die
terrorherrschaft der nazis und es ist
eine forderung die bis heute besteht
auch in anderen verfassungen finden sich
diese sätze in europäischen ländern oder
auch den usa
aber was sind diese forderungen nach
menschlichkeit wert wenn es um den krieg
gegen den terrorismus geht ich möchte
heute sprechen im dialog mit professor
rainer maus feld von der universität in
kiel
da gibt es den römischen satz den die
lateiner gebildet haben der heißt in
zeiten des krieges da herrschen andere
gesetze wir haben seit 2001 gelernt dass
staaten diesen satz ernst nehmen könnte
so etwas auf uns zukommen
das kann sicherlich auch auf uns
zukommen
wir haben zwar nach langen und sehr
blutigen erfahrungen in der geschichte
der menschheit versucht einen
rechtlichen balken einzuziehen gegen
diese art der erfahrung aber dieser
balken mussten natürlich immer wieder
verteidigt werden
er muss rechtlich verstärkt werden
aber es kann natürlich immer wieder in
entsprechenden situationen dazu kommen
dass wir einen rückschritt hinter das
bereich bereits erreichte bekommen da
reicht relativ es reicht relativ wenig
wir sprechen miteinander unter dem
eindruck verschiedenster ereignisse wir
haben die veröffentlichung der cia
folterer reports details muss man schon
sagen über 1000 seiten
wir haben attentate in paris wir haben
reaktionen in der bevölkerung wir haben
die drohungen dass so etwas auch bei uns
passieren kann in deutschland wie geht
eine gesellschaft um oder wie verändert
sie sich wie kann man das zum beispiel
an amerikanischen gesellschaft sehen
nach den terroranschlägen vom 11
september das ist sicherlich kein
automatismus sondern eine gesellschaft
hat immer die wahl wie sie mit solchen
ereignissen um geht und der mensch hat
mehrere gesichter
wir können also in der gesellschaft eine
politik verfolgen die sagen wir mal das
gute im menschen hervor holt oder stärkt
oder wir können eine politik verfolgen
die die destruktiven anteil die die
negativen seiten des menschen verstärkt
und man hatte bisweilen den eindruck
dass diese ereignisse auch vom staat
genutzt werden um einen echten oder
vermeintlichen sicherheitsanspruch zu
bekräftigen
bevor wir jetzt über das sprechen was
unter anderem im report steht über die
entwicklung auch historische entwicklung
die folterungen in den usa und außerhalb
der usa wie schmal ist denn die grenze
zwischen der menschlichkeit und
mitmenschlichkeit und dem wo menschen
oder auch die politik bereit ist
einschränkungen vorzunehmen
das sind eigentlich genau die beiden
seiten die der mensch hat wir sind als
menschen zu empathie befähigt wir sind
also in der lage erfahrungen durch die
augen anderer zu machen und diese
befähigung ermöglicht uns eigentlich
empfänglich für das leiden anderer zu
sein
gleichzeitig haben wir eine einzigartige
befähigung andere aus der gültigkeit der
rechte die wir für uns beanspruchen
auszugrenzen und zwar auf der basis im
grunde x-beliebiger merkmale das kann
hautfarbe sein das kann geschlechtliche
orientierung sein das kann herkunft sein
das kann religion sein es reicht sehr
wenig was aktiviert werden kann um den
anderen nicht mehr das zu sprechen was
für für uns beanspruchen
und das ist natürlich aufgabe einer
gesellschaft auch eine start ist dafür
zu sorgen dass dieses ausgrenzung spot
enzian was wir natürlicherweise haben
nicht zusätzlich noch aktiviert wird
das heißt ich behandle jemanden nicht
mehr wie ich selber behandelt werden
will genau das heißt ich mache eine
grenze zwischen mir und einem anderen
der nicht auf einer stufe steht das ist
sozusagen auch angelegt in
gesellschaften wo es sklaven gab wo es
menschen gab unter menschen gab auch
diesen begriff hatte es ja gegeben in
der deutschen geschichte
das heißt man macht unterschiede und
dann darf man mit denen auch anders
umgehen
ja der andere der andere kann nicht dass
beanspruchen was wir für uns
beanspruchen
und in dem moment wo ich jemand als den
anderen aus grenze gelten für ihn gelten
für ihn die dinge nicht mehr die wir für
uns beanspruchen und die gesamte
geschichte zeigt in der tat sklaven
durften im alten rom gefoltert werden
römer nicht in griechenland waren es die
barbaren die gefoltert werden durften
und in der europäischen geschichte in
der kolonialgeschichte waren auch waren
es immer die anderen
es gab keine folter in europa sondern
die folter fand in den kolonien statt
und diese möglichkeit den anderen als
den anderen auszugrenzen aus diesem
gültigkeitsbereich ermöglicht uns unsere
werte
unser selbstbild was wir auch zum teil
aus der aufklärung übernommen haben
aufrecht zu erhalten
wir sind eigentlich die guten bis auf
die die eben nicht zu uns gehören
das heißt aber auch eine französische
revolution bei der es dann den anspruch
der menschenrechte zunächst aber für
alle
ab oder auch die ride of bild das heißt
die forderung der amerikanischen
verfassung lässt sich einschränken dann
wenn ich sage der höhere gehört gar
nicht zu mir
genau das ist im grunde wie die
athenischen demokratie die auch hieß es
eine demokratie fürs volk mit ausnahme
natürlich von fremden von frauen
das galt ja bei uns auch noch für die
demokratie mit dem wahlrecht das haben
wir in der europäischen geschichte auch
dass wir sagen ja für alle die
tatsächlich echte menschen sind also
meinesgleichen die genauso sind wie ich
für die gilt dass aber jemand der nicht
voll dazu gehört da wurden feine
abstufung gemacht in der geschichte
frauen gehörten zum etwas größeren
prozentsatz dazu als schwarz und so
weiter aber das durchzieht eigentlich
unser land wenn tisches denken
wann ist der mensch man ist eine person
an charakter in der lage diese
unterscheidung zu treffen
das an ist er bereit dafür zu sagen das
ist etwas anderes als ich selber das ist
ein anderer eine andere art von mensch
oder lebewesen das ist eine interessante
frage weil es eine angeborene ist eine
angeborene kategorisierung die wir mit
zu welt bringen die der säugling schon
macht es gibt faszinierende experimente
in der psychologie wo man zeigen kann
dass der säugling schon bestimmte eine
angeborene proto moral sagt man dazu hat
wo er bestimmte fairness anforderungen
für andere stellt sobald er aber
beteiligt ist nutznießer sozusagen einer
verteilung sind die nicht mehr in kraft
also für mich gelten andere gelten
andere regeln als bei der beurteilung
anderer das ist wenn wenn sie so wollen
könnte man sagen wir verfügen über eine
angeborene doppelmoral eine doppelmoral
die aber in welchem fall nutzbar ist
oder ausgenutzt werden kann denn wir
sprechen ja auch über die politik genau
aufgabe der zivilisations entwicklung
ist eigentlich dem rechnung zu tragen
und rechtliche balken gegen diese unsere
natur einzuziehen
beispielsweise mit der idee der
universellen menschenrechte die idee der
universellen menschenrechte ist uns
eigentlich fremd weil der andere
natürlich nicht so sein kann wie wir
also ist es eine art kultureller
erziehungsprozess
ein zivilisatorischer erziehungsprozess
da hinzukommen zu sagen diese rechte
soll sollen
das ist keine diskreditiere feststellung
dass eine normative feststellung diese
rechte sollen für alle gleich sein so
wollen wir das im grunde genommen eine
vereinbarung darüber alle menschen als
gleichwertig und als wert zu betrachten
genau auf einer ebene wann wird diese
ebene eingeschränkt wann bin ich bereit
den anderen sie haben eben von den
experimenten gesprochen dann bin ich
bereit diese einschränkung zu machen und
zu sagen der gehört nicht zu mir ist das
ein äußerer ein psychischer druck werde
ich in eine besondere situation gebracht
oder wann wann mache ich diese
unterscheidung wir sind jederzeit dazu
bereit das kann man den stadtteilen
beobachten das kann man zwischen
verschiedenen kulturen beobachten
das kann man zwischen hautfarben
geschlechter orientierung wir sind jeder
jederzeit dazu bereit
es ist eigentlich nur ein kultur prozess
der uns daran hindert diese seite zu
aktivieren
gehen wir mal zurück auf das was seit
2001 in den usa passiert ist und
außerhalb der usa
da gab es einen sogenannten kampf gegen
den terrorismus ein kampf gegen den
terror da haben die amerikaner die us
amerikaner entschieden wir werden von
außen bedroht wir müssen darauf
reagieren das ist eine art krieg damit
wurde dann auch legitimiert und
legalisiert denn vom präsidenten bush
stammen diese legalisierung also die
unterschriften dass man mit
unmenschlichkeit menschen behandeln darf
um angeblich das eigene volk zu schützen
der krieg gegen den terrorismus ist ist
eigentlich viel älter als der elfte
september er geht zurück auf ronald
reagan der genau mit diesem konzept
krieg gegen den terrorismus das als eine
art strategie zur durchsetzung
politischer ziele
weil der krieg gegen den terrorismus ja
nicht ein krieg ist im echten sinne
es gibt keine kriterien wann er beendet
sein könnte er ist ein krieg der
eigentlich
nicht lange fortsetzbar ist und in eine
art rechtsfreien raum stattfindet das
mag aus sicht eines staates ein sehr
machtvolles instrument sein aber es ist
für die entwicklung die wir haben mit
universellen menschenrechten in der tat
eine fatale entwicklung
was ist denn da aus ihrer sicht seit
2001 passiert wir haben jetzt eben schon
gesagt 1000 seiten vorliegen von einem
report der detailliert die
unmenschlichkeit beschreibt in der
mitgefangenen umgegangen worden ist mit
angeblichen terroristen oder
tatsächlichen terroristen
da wo immer einschränkungen gemacht
wurde wurden im sinne von das muss jetzt
geschehen um andere zu schonen zu
schützen
ja der senatsbericht zeigt ja
gleichzeitig dass das reine propaganda
war dass der tatsächliche nutzen für die
schutzfunktion die eigentlich intendiert
war de facto bei null war das
vernachlässigbar es wurde kein einziges
menschenleben durch die folter gerettet
ist wurde kein anschlag verhindert da
wird aber immer wieder gesagt man hätte
al kaida und osama bin laden nie
maßgeblich bekämpfen können hätte ihn
nie gefunden ohne folter was ja nicht
nachweislich des senats bericht ist
nicht stimmt dass genau das was der
senatsbericht er zeigt diese aussage des
eeg sei falsch und das ist auch eine
eigentlich etwas was amerikanische
sicherheitsexperten von fbi verhör
experten und militärische für höchst
werden immer gesagt haben die
informationen die durch folter gewonnen
worden sind waren wertlos
aber was ist dann diese form der
unmenschlichkeit die folter eigentlich
wert warum ist es ein mittel was
eingesetzt wird wenn man weiß dass die
wahrheit damit nicht unbedingt ans
tageslicht kommt die behauptung dass es
eine beziehung zwischen folter und
wahrheit gibt da ist natürlich schon
schon sehr lange bekannt
dass die vollständig falsch ist die
wahrheit kommt nicht unser schmerz
zutage sondern man produziert eigentlich
nur falsch geständnis weil jemand die
folter der folter entgehen entgehen
möchte es müssen also andere gründe
seien es war nicht die es war nicht die
nacht nachrichtendienstliche wert der zu
folter geführt hat sondern es waren
eigentlich
es ist eine folter ist eine macht
technik und war es eigentlich immer die
folge ist eine macht technik zur
erniedrigung und um schrecken unter den
zu verbreiten die wir als unsere feinde
ansehen wenn wir uns mal anschauen
bilder von guantanamo und alamo was
immer wieder dafür steht die amerikaner
nach dem elften september
terrorverdächtige inhaftiert haben und
gefoltert haben
wir sehen immer wieder die gleichen
bilder die uns jetzt schon inzwischen
ein bisschen abstumpfen lassen weil man
sie gar nicht mehr so furchtbar findet
wie sie sind und was sie zeigen wo
beginnt denn für sie unmenschlichkeit
bzw folter tatsächlich folter zu sein
das ist in der tat eine eine schwierige
frage obwohl obwohl wir eigentlich keine
schwierigkeiten haben sie zu beantworten
wenn wir den ce bericht lesen wenn wir
die berichte von amnesty international
und anderen menschenrechtsorganisationen
lesen dann sehen wir das ist zweifellos
folter warum sind wir uns also sicher
weil wir als menschen eine universelle
begriffs vorstellung haben was zwang ist
wir möchten nicht in unseren natürlichen
physiologischen psychischen physischen
befähigung möchten wir nicht gehindert
werden office ob s umsehen geht um hören
um schlafen um soziale kontakte haben
und so weiter und wir leiden wenn uns
jemand in einer totalitären situation in
der er absolute gewalt über uns hat an
dieser ausführung
hindert folter ist also wenn ich
jemanden dem willen eines anderen zu
einem bloßen objekt mache was dem willen
alles andere untergeordnet ist
jetzt ist das problem wenn es so einfach
wenn wir eine eine so verlässliche
intuition darüber haben was folter ist
warum ist es dann so schwierig diese
vorstellung begrifflich juristisch auch
in einen rechtsrahmen zu fassen
da wäre natürlich eine eine klare
definition wünschenswert doch die gibt
es nicht und die kann es nicht geben
das ist eine ganz normale situation in
der rechtsentwicklung die ist hier nicht
anders als im falle von sklaverei
völkermord und kriegsverbrechen
man kann also nur einen kern präzisieren
versuchen einen kern zu fassen warum es
beim vorfall bei der folter geht nämlich
um einen schweren angriff auf die würde
des menschen und das ist genau das was
der internationale und nationale
rechtsrahmen versuchen jetzt wird immer
wieder das problem seien weniger diesen
begriff zu fassen als zu sagen wann
bestimmte maßnahmen bestimmter
verhörtechniken angewendet werden dürfen
und was schon nicht mehr legitim ist
oder nicht legal ist wir haben einen
sehr aufsehenerregenden fall selbst in
deutschland erlebt bei der entführung
eines jungen eines elfjährigen jungen
der von einem entführer entführt worden
ist und sofort umgebracht worden ist und
bei dem verhör ist im jahr 2002 ein
polizist hingegangen und hat angedroht
demjenigen denen er im verdacht hatte
wenn er das versteck und den
möglicherweise noch lebenden jungen
nicht herausrückt gewalt anzuwenden ist
dass folter aus ihrer sicht das ist die
androhung von folter die verboten ist
sie haben die zwei aspekte angesprochen
einmal die grenzziehung von folter und
grausame behandlung
interessanterweise stellen alle
internationalen norm und regularien dazu
zb die allgemeine erklärung der
menschenrechte von 48 stellt fest
niemand darf der folter oder
unmenschlicher einen niedrigen der
entwürdigende behandlung unterzogen
werden es geht nicht um eine scharfe
grenzziehung von folter und
unmenschlicher behandlung sondern beides
ist gleichermaßen verboten zwar absolut
verboten weil es an den würde kern des
menschen geht
das heißt eigentlich müssten diese
formulierung die spitzfindigkeiten die
gerne von juristen gemacht werden zu
sagen wir müssen unterscheiden ist es
schon echte folter oder nur ein bisschen
folter rumsfeld war ja sehr hat er sehr
viel subtile unterscheidung da
eingebracht die sind eigentlich durch
die allgemeine erklärung der
menschenrechte der boden entzogen
in anderen punkt den sie ansprechen in
einer ganz anderen art von beziehung in
dem fall dass es gibt in dem komplexen
gewebe von moral moral recht und alters
situation kann es situationen geben in
denen etwas gemacht werden muss was
gemacht werden muss obwohl es nicht
rechtlich und moralisch zu rechtfertigen
ist auch dadurch dass es gemacht wird
darf es nicht als als moralischen
rechtlich rechtfertigte ansehen
es kann sein dass situation gibt da muss
so etwas gemacht werden
aber damit ist es nicht recht nicht
legitimiert der fall gegen bzw der fall
metzler von metzler ist ja der
klassische fall bei dem man fragt muss
man nicht ein mittel einsetzen nämlich
die androhung von gewalt oder tat
sichtlich durchgeführter gewalt um ein
leben zu retten ist es dann legitim bzw
illegal egal ist es nicht aber ist es
dann legitim
es ist im grunde so dass man sagen dass
es gibt solche situationen für die es
kein recht das recht ist nicht für
extremsituationen gemacht es gibt
situationen wo eine solche handlung
machen muss aber dadurch sind sie weder
legitim noch legal das folterverbot ist
absolut darauf bezieht sich auch die
androhung von folter
weil folter und rechtsstaat sich
gegenseitig widersprechen wenn gefoltert
wird gibt es keinen rechtsstaat mehr
aber das heißt die amerikaner haben sich
im falle von guantanamo von abu ghraib
von anderen gefängnissen auch im ausland
einer logistik bedient die dazu diente
das amerikanische volk die us-bürger vor
neuen terroranschlägen zu schützen ist
es dann erlaubt diese techniken
anzuwenden nicht einmal mehr wenn die
prämisse stimmen würde dass man durch
die folter anschläge verhindern könnte
wäre sie erlaubt weil in allen in allen
gesetzen die sich auf das folterverbot
beziehen eindeutig steht die die das
folterverbot ist eine nützlichkeit
abwägung vollständig entzogen
folter darf nicht einer
nützlichkeitserwägungen und es wird
explizit weil die natürlich die das
formuliert haben geahnt haben dass ist
der diskussion gibt es wird explizit vom
geht nicht einmal im falle eines starts
notstandes oder einer kriegsgefahr was
verhindert dass wenn wir das als
grundsatz erklären
das verhinderte das verhindert dass die
folter offiziell legitimiert werden kann
die folter darf nicht durch nützlichkeit
aspekte
das ist eigentlich ausgeschlossen wenn
wir uns anschauen welche logistik
welches netzwerk
die amerikanischen geheimdienste
entwickelt haben um zum beispiel
terrorismus verdächtige in andere länder
zu bringen dass syrien zu bringen
nach polen zu bringen wo sie gefoltert
werden konnten ohne dass man zugeben
musste sie werden in den usa gefoltert
was steht da möglicherweise für eine
politische idee dahinter
da stehen natürlich jede menge
politischen interessen verbündete zu
gewinnen verbündete erpressbar zu halten
indem man sie reinzieht in dieses gewebe
da gibt es eine ganze eine ganze große
gemenge lage von von politischen
interessen
was ist in keinem fall ist es
informationsbeschaffung man müsste sich
eigentlich noch mal deutlich machen was
eigentlich die aufgaben der seal sind
die aufgaben des ea sind verdeckte
militärische operation global in einem
rechtsfreien raum durchführen zu können
und die aufgaben des ea sind wird auch
im senatsbericht weil es hier ja auch
den senat belogen hat massiv
desinformation zu betreiben
das heißt ein teil dieser folterungen
sind passiert um falsche geständnisse es
gibt einen oberst steven klein wenn der
genau ein verhör spezialist der das
gesagt hat dass ihr ging es eigentlich
darum falsche geständnisse zu bekommen
um kriegs angst zu schüren und die
kriegsbereitschaft die amerikaner
aufrecht zu erhalten
dann ist aber das was dort an praktiken
angewandt worden ist gar nicht eine
praktik die tatsächlich dazu führen
sollte dass es aussagen gab die eine
hilfe bei der aufdeckung von möglichen
terror akten waren sondern es ging
eigentlich nur darum einen willen einen
menschen zu brechen
genau es ging nur darum und das ist hat
von anfang an konflikte gegeben zwischen
erfahrenen verhörspezialisten wie sie
beim fbi gibt erfahrenen
verhörspezialisten wie sie beim militär
gibt die von anfang an die abgelehnt
haben weil sie wussten die folter
produzierten eigentlich nur
falschinformation es hat sehr massive
schon es gab ja schon ein erstes
überraschendes gab einen ersten senats
bericht 2009
der auch in der öffentlichkeit bekannt
wurde mit den ganzen folter techniken
die wir jetzt haben
da war das auch schon genannt welche
konfliktes zwischen den diensten gab wo
die dienste selbst gesagt haben die
folter ist vollständig unbrauchbar
es gibt ein bericht eines inhaftierten
in guantánamo dieser 13 jahren dort
inhaftiert ist ein sehr langen bericht
geliefert hat über das was er dort
erlebt hat er hat mehrere tausend seiten
protokolle abgeliefert die aber zu
eigentlich nichts geführt haben
er ist ein gebrochener mensch es
gebrochen worden durch verschiedene
verhörmethoden
es gibt die vorher methode des
waterboarding was ja auch eigentlich auf
mittelalterliche foltermethoden
zurückzuführen ist was passiert da auf
dauer mit einem menschen der solchen
dingen ausgesetzt ist die technik die
folter techniken die überwiegend an
gesetze angewandt werden sind ja nicht
einfach für im mittelalter dass man rein
körperliche verletzungen zufügt sondern
die folter techniken sind übrigens mit
hilfe meiner zunft psychologen sind
optimiert worden um die seele eines
menschen zu brechen
das heißt dass selbst eines menschen
wird zerstört die psychische intaktheit
eines menschen wird zerstört während die
äußere hülle intakt bleibt
und das ist eigentlich das schlimme weil
eine solche weil eine solche person
nicht einmal mehr die empathie der
anderen bekommt weil man ihm nicht
ansieht
an diesen folgen und er hat nun ein
eigenartiges verhalten das ist das was
man so auch als weiße folter bestimmen
das heißt das sind verhörtechniken die
man quasi nicht erkennen kann die person
ist aber dennoch gebrochen
und man muss davon ausgehen dass eine
solche person auch nicht mehr gesunden
kann nein die kann in der regel solche
traumatisierung sind so schwer dass man
die in der regel auch durch therapien
nicht mehr reparieren kann
nun haben die amerikaner aber auch
andere
geheimdienste anderer länder sehr
logistisch sehr konzentriert ganz viele
zünfte eingesetzt
sie haben gerade von den psychologen
gesprochen auch die ärzte werden
inzwischen eingesetzt um möglichst gute
verhörtechniken zu finden in
anführungsstrichen da gibt es auch einen
wandel von den verhörspezialisten sie
haben es gerade gesagt der fb des fbi
hinzu militärführer spezialisten das ist
ganz bewusst gemacht worden weil man
beim militär eben über eine sicherung
nach außen hin verfügte da durfte
niemand etwas von wissen das konnte man
abwehren was ist denn zu befürchten im
hinblick auf diese verletzung der
menschenrechte auch in der westlichen
welt auch in den ländern die diese würde
des menschen für unantastbar halten für
eine entwicklung wie wir sie im
augenblick haben einer bedrohung von
außen durch terrorismus einer unruhe in
der bevölkerung wenn es tatsächlich zu
einem terroranschlag kommt der hebel um
solche verfahren durchzusetzen war ja
genau den den sie eingangs angesprochen
haben zu sagen wir müssen trennen
zwischen echter folter und
unmenschlicher behandlung echte folter
sollte nicht sein aber unmenschliche
behandlung muss in bestimmten
situationen sein
das sind unterscheidungen die natürlich
gemacht werden um die absolutheit den
absolut heitzler verbots zu unterlaufen
und da haben viele juristen mediziner
psychologen daran mitgewirkt diese
unterscheidung aufrecht zu halten
die aber nach den rechtsrahmen sich
nicht nicht zulässig ist wenn wir eine
situation kommen in der wir auch aus der
bevölkerung einer reaktion haben im
sinne von wir müssen uns dagegen wehren
wir müssen jetzt etwas tun da muss man
auch mal dinge zu lassen die wir in
einer normalen lage nicht zulassen
würden
wie verändert sich eine gesellschaft
eigentlich durch ein solches offenheit
gegenüber unmenschlichkeit
verfügen wir leider auch über
hinreichende historische erfahrungen
man kann auch da nur sagen alles ist
möglich und es hängt wesentlich davon ab
wie eine gesellschaft als ganzes auf
eine solche situation reagiert und da
sind natürlich bestimmte gruppen
politiker medien ganz besonders gefragt
um diese diskussion in eine richtige
richtung zu leiten
der staat hat natürlich immer jedem
staat wohnt sozusagen erstarrt eine
totalitäre versuchungen der staat möchte
jede dieser situation nutzen um sein
sicherheitsbereich auszuweiten
das heißt dem start ist das ist ja eine
rhetorik die sich häufig findet zu sagen
wir müssen den rechtsstaat aufgeben um
ihn zu schützen
die logik des sicherheits staates ist ja
gerade das ist ja welcher neusprech wir
müssen demokratie abbauen
um sie zu schützen das heißt man muss
nach mehreren seiten gehen wir müssen
für verhüten dass der staat sein
sicherheitsanspruch immer größer macht
es hat ja damals der damalige
innenminister schäuble formuliert ist
darf was die innere sicherheit angeht
keine tabus und keine denkverbote geben
das ist eigentlich das was mittlerweile
passiert ist die folter war tabuisiert
das neue nach nine eleven war nicht die
folter die folter ist eine kontinuität
durch die gesamte nachkriegszeit
die finden wir von lateinamerika
philippinen das neue ist nicht die
folter das neue ist dass die folter
öffentlich verteidigt wurde
die folter war bis dahin tabuisiert mann
leugnete sie wenn sie wenn es herauskam
hat man sie verdammt verurteilt sie war
tabuisiert dieses tabu ist gefallen das
ist das eigentlich schreckliche
was durch die bush regierung die
legalisierung legitimität der folge
was ist aber wenn wir auf die deutsche
gesellschaft schauen vielleicht noch im
hinterkopf der deutschen aus der nazi
herrschaft sozusagen übrig geblieben an
abwehrmechanismus ist dennoch stark
genug um bei ähnlichen situationen wir
haben gerade zu beginn über paris
gesprochen über die attentate von paris
zu reagieren und zu sagen wir heben dann
doch nicht grundlagen unserer
zivilisation auf wenn wir in eine solche
situation geraten
das kollektive gedächtnis ist leider
extrem kurz wir haben ja die
errungenschaften die wir in diesem
bereich haben durch eine
rechtsentwicklung immer nur gewonnen
nach nach gigantischen katastrophen
gigantische katastrophen haben dazu
geführt dass der dass der mensch in den
spiegel seiner selbst schaut und über
sein antlitz erschrocken ist und sagt
das wollen wir nicht mehr das wollen wir
nicht mehr und nur nach solchen
situationen war man bereit die
universellen menschenrechte und ähnliche
rechtsrahmen zu entwickeln
wenn das gedächtnis in dem moment wo
diese dinge aus dem gedächtnis
verschwinden ist in der bevölkerung die
bereitschaft groß an diesen
errungenschaften wieder zu knabbern
wir finden also immer ein prozess es
geht ein stück hoch und dann wieder eine
zeit in der diese dinge abgebaut werden
und man muss sagen was wir heute in den
usa haben ist ein massiver rückschritt
hinter das was wir in den nürnberger
prozessen
woher dieses recht durch die amerikaner
formuliert worden ist was wir im statut
von rom und im internationalen
strafgerichtshof in den haag haben wir
haben eine einige balken eingezogen
diese balken verschwinden jetzt wieder
weil gesagt wird sie sind nicht legitim
das heißt aber das gedächtnis
der amerikaner die die nürnberger
prozesse durchgeführt haben die erlebt
haben bis ins detail wie die nazi
herrschaft als terror instrument auch um
menschlichkeit und folter eingesetzt hat
dieses versichert mit der zeit und man
hat einen so großen abstand dazu dass
man das nicht mehr in der aktualität
wachrufen kann ja wir lernen wir lernen
nur durch schmerzliche erfahrungen und
es ist natürlich aufgabe der
gesellschaft diese erfahrungen
wachzuhalten und auch die erinnerung
immer wieder wachzurufen
aber was müsste denn was müssten
verantwortliche in der politik tun um zu
verhindern dass es möglicherweise wir
reden von einer prävention bei einer
ähnlichen lage wie in anderen ländern im
zusammenhang mit terrorakten zu solchen
reaktionen in der bevölkerung kommt
ängste deeskalieren er müsse so vorgehen
wie bei anderen verbrechen auch wie beim
bankraub und bei anderen wir haben ein
strafrecht man muss diese dinge nicht
gleich auf eine prinzipielle ebene der
andere sind die anderen als gruppe die
schuld sind sondern wir haben strafrecht
um diese dinge zu verfolgen
aber der staat hat natürlich ein anderes
interesse der staat möchte diese
situation nutzen um seine
sicherheitsbelange weiterzutreiben das
ist natürlich auch eine eine alte lehre
aus der geschichte tat sie tue sagte
schon bedrohlich bedrohlich ist das volk
für die herrschenden wenn es ohne furcht
ist also ist gerade ganz wichtig die
furcht dass angst einflößen ist eine
ganz ist ein ganz wichtiges
machtinstrument und der staat nutzt
natürlich dankbar diese art von vorfälle
um seine eigene agenda zu betreiben so
wie sie das beschreiben ist das wenig
optimistisch für den fall der fälle
bleibt ein bisschen optimismus bei ihnen
trotzdem übrig dass man auch in einem
solchen fall von terrorismus in
deutschland besonnen reagiert das ist
ganz schwer vorherzusagen weil es an
denen natürlich in erster linie liegt
die wichtige
liga touren sind es liegt an der
sogenannten geistigen elite es liegt an
den medien es liegt an denen die eine
stimmung aufgreifen und verstärken die
erfahrung auch nach nine eleven ist
leider dass die geistigen eliten muss
sagen wieder einmal versagt haben das
waren juristen das waren psychologen das
waren auch die medien die new york times
hat es im letzten jahr ist es dazu
übergegangen das wort folter auch zu
verwendet wurde vorher mit
beschönigungen um schweben mann hatte
sich in den medien eigentlich darauf
geeinigt wir wissen dass es folter ist
aber wir nennen es nicht so das heißt
die verantwortung gewichtigste
verantwortung liegt eigentlich bei denen
die große multiplikatoren für die diese
dinge sind
mein optimismus ist eher begrenzt muss
ich gestiegen
leider danke für das gespräch professor
dankeschön dass in dem fall